[Applauso]
adesso oggi scopriamo dallo squalo di
rob lowe
molto simile al topo di robles vi
ricordate quanto già fatto impazzire
questa volta se lo squalo come ce la
caveremo quante volte si mangerà lo
squalo
mettete poi mi piace front man
di bob carivit e abuso vino così qua
come potete vedere se mangiano sano
l'acqua stiamo nuotando è ma cosa c
valori cia odori e dori di della ricerca
di nancy
voltare stai molto attento perché lassù
ti mangia quale squadra vuole squadra
vediamo se siete dei nostri super super
fan in quale video vitale ha detto quale
squalo square ma lo ricordi coperto
entriamo attento che ti potrebbe essere
ovunque mentre non camminare ma a
nuotare così ho sentito rumore acqua
zona
qui nei forse premi q ma più veloce
finito meglio che conservi le energie
per quando arriverà lo squalo è sì me ne
sono accorto che questa roma io che ho
preso un osso e dobbiamo prenderne 6 o
se dobbiamo prendere prese le mosse di
troppo ciao rizzo ei ma perché tu invece
di nuotare time non lo so tenuta di mare
verso tu stai lottando in modo diverso
ognuno si vede in maniera diversa dove
ok ho preso uno degli a uno l'ho preso
pure io mi sa questo l'ho presa pure io
sì ci sentiamo l'uscita prima che arrivi
la squalo tutti dell arizona in cui non
può entrare la squadra è chi sembra
abbastanza tranquillo sbaglio perché non
parla questo mistero questo ha detto
vuoi che ti dica qualcosa ma se tale
premiamo si i giornali nascondono i
segreti e come faccio ad aprire questa
baule c'è una chiave rosso forse serve
la chiave rosso è una chiave rossa
dovrei trovata era trovata qui in giro
la scuola nuovamente noto dove ne ho
mangiato eccolo che tu ecco i resti di
milano
c'è un codice
[Applauso]
che i ragazzi ricordiamoci il codice
4189 sicuramente si serviva per offrire
qualcosa evitare affetto lì così
entriamo si sono poi vicino sto
mangiando quella quella c'è un piatto
fondo c'è un piatto in testa non mi dire
che ora rincorrere per cercare di rubare
cibo intera è certo secondo me questo
cappello lo dovresti mettere tutto è
vero che si prende tutte sei troppo la
qualche polo aiuto quando c'è questa
musica vuol dire che si sta s di un
labirinto
proprio come in quello del dopo un
errore delle cose potevate capo verde
non so cosa servirà ma lo scopriremo
assieme a un altro osso dove e come
faccio a spiegartelo nell'abbinare
comuni dietro di te
scusa
[Musica]
che li devo riprendere la
quale
ho scoperto che praticamente da quando
si apre questa stanza col codice aspetto
aspetto ha trovato una crosta trovato
ancora senza colpa di farla rientrata a
devi togliere tutti quei numeri
spiegarmi quattro mura ma perché
accaduto prometto che mi
chiamo il codice è sì giusto fare tutto
9 ok
adesso non mi fa entrare 4189 di
differente
e forse perché ci sono io dentro
comunque
sto trovato un sacco di cose con dentro
quindi devo prendere la chiave prima di
entrare se ti consiglio di prendere una
chiave verde rossoblù ecco la scuola
si è preso però mi serve a capire perché
comunque qui si può camminare
bene quindi non sei più sott'acqua non
sei uno squalo no non c'è lo squalo
caso qualcuno ha creato qualcuno o forse
il codice è cambiato ecco perché ha una
volta
forse in quella stanza devi prendere
qualcosa per aprire poi queste porre e
credo di sì infatti storia mi ha preso
ecco la chiave rossa ok io prenderò la
chiave era un'altra chiave allora o
quella verde o quella blu ok così
possiamo aprirli insieme prima lavori si
rientrare la terra però
si sa cosa dice sempre 4189 un altro che
mai prima non si aperto che strano
questo eravamo in troppi
tu che avevi preso quella ha stretto
ancora nostro lato invece qua c'è una
porta per aprirla ci vuole o il martello
un martello
quasi una scala addirittura come porta
quella scala o che ci prova a rientrare
e poi prova andare nella scala ma perché
io non riesco a trovare nulla di tutto
questo
ok carlo sica entrare anche si può
finalmente
attenta anno prenderti la stessa
determinati dal team ha infatti ma tu
hai saltato sì io ho saltato pensato
che dietro c'è lo squalo perché non ci
pare
una parte parliamo prima ora sto andando
più veloce per miraculusi scapperà i
vicini quasi zero non mi ricordo di
avere la chiave molto forse parte qua ci
mancherebbe
sono riuscito a scappare ho preso la
chiave verde nei trofei la chiave verde
lo passa io non ti preoccupare ok
lavorato berlino devo trovare la chiave
rossa tu dove sei non ti vedo andando
dove c'è il codice dove c'è la porta
norme non sono riuscito ad attraversare
questa parte
il problema è che non ho nessuna chiave
perché lo squalo quando mi ha preso me
l'ha presa ma cosa però qua dietro un
baule magico
non sono riuscito a capire come si apre
rosell fa qualcosa forse dobbiamo
scoprire qualcosa qua va bene ora vado a
prendere una delle chiavi quando la
scuola è qua fuori che mi aspettano foto
gira da qua
tour in trappola
ecco noi si sta aspettando che ho
trovato la chiave rossa e subito dopo il
codice e io provo a trovare quella verde
allora così magari possiamo entrare
insieme sì così possiamo aprire due
bauli primo che non arrivi adesso sembra
purché non sia qui o no è proprio lì che
mi aspetta dove se il codice è da meno
che c'è il codice ok allora adesso che
trovo la chiave verde magari proviamo a
distrarlo lo devi avere un attimo di
pazienza
per fortuna allora poi c'è una chiara
una situazione
non mi ricordo davvero la chimica verde
ho trovato quella rossa ma io quando mi
nascondo fa no non ha funzionato
nasconderti
[Musica]
lo squalo forse quando può passare per
viva devo aspettare che si allontani
dalla porta con il codice così posso
entrare aprire il baule rotto a ho
trovato la chiave verde bravissimo video
ma allora ci incontriamo alla porta con
il come dice la porta con il codice però
mi devi aspettare ok forse sono vicino
sono vicino alla porta con il codice
bene
riapre il pregiato è come se volessi
centro ambientale fa ok allora possiamo
aprire i bauli lo spirito è bene che
questa troviamo cosa dobbiamo saltare
qui sui laser
sfracellati altrimenti perderanno
lucio fatto che abbiamo un baule vediamo
cosa ci aspetta ma prima di aprirlo
volevo ringraziarvi perché in tanti
e molti lo avete già finito di leggere
tutto ma che ci nei commenti se ce
l'avessero avete letto qual è la vostra
creatura preferita con la nostra storia
preferita leggiamo sempre i vostri
commenti grazie davvero siamo
felicissimi che vi piaccia così tanto e
ora pronti apriamo il ba1 ammesso mi
chiamo il predetto ok adesso a ognuno di
noi deve mettere la chiave quindi che
vedi io vedo l'okay su una chiave verde
tournée di l'okay solo sulla crisi anche
per aprirli d'oro
facciate blu non l'ho vista da nessuna
parte
chi però se vicino al codice chiede
dov'è boh chi si ricorda che avete
lasciato mi piace se non avete ancora
stato cui piace era stata un baby calcio
copia sotto è se questo video raggiunge
i 5 mila mi piace proveremo altri giochi
fini in cui bisogna scappare come questo
che è tipo quello del top ecco la chiave
vederlo così ma
[Musica]
non solo stretto il rumore 4189 è
perfetto
ma chiave bluetooth non c'entra né bravo
usa non riuscite a entrare nomi sono
sfracellata o da dove ritrovare la
chiave verde ok
eh già io oggi ho messo due chiavi mi
manca solo la chiave blu dove si troverà
legava brothers fretta come il gioco del
topo è un gioco perché ti fa venire idee
da vedere se questa volta non mi devo
accettare da quel cavolo di rage da lo
sapevo guarda ogni volta che devo andare
io a vincere ma quando poi non te ne vai
bisogna distrarlo e
continuando a tenermi
ok non devo sfracellarsi non devo brace
allarmi si
trovano a vivere perché aiutati
sfracella sempre ma veramente tutti i
fratelli sempre è vincolato l'ho fatta
ok manca solo la chiave blu che però non
abbiamo mai visto che devono parte
assolo continuando a cercarla ma non lo
trova e io un'idea seguiamo questo
giocatore forse lui è più bravo 0 ma
questo è un trucchetto quando siete
bloccati in una mappa mentre giocate a
rho blocks seguire qualche altro
giocatore perché a volte sono più
esperti
e questo un martello trasferì avrò preso
problema è che non c'è nessuna chiave
blu
dove sarà se la chiave blu compare
quando si prendono tutti gli ossicini ha
un'idea proviamo a tornare in quella
stanza e vediamo se c'è qualcosa di
nascosto attorno ai pauli o vicino ai
pauli quasi fiume rossa
per un pelo era verde le posso prendere
due si possa produrre nel vivo nuovo
allora vediamo
controlliamo bene questo baule è molto
strano ma non accade niente può prova
cliccare ma non fa niente
sono entrata dentro i bauli ma lo stesso
non ne so niente
grazie a
questa chiave
esiste
ne ho mangiato ok ragazzi allora l'altro
gioco purtroppo non si trovava da verso
la parte da chi avrebbe governato brutta
che il tempo quindi abbiamo cambiato
gioco però lo stesso gioco degli squali
charme
ora devo scegliere la barchetta e scelgo
questa colorata c'è scritto attenzione
ci sono gli squali con dopo giorno
aspettando
prova a cadere in acqua e vediamo cosa
succede
ma dov'è la mia barchetta e può causare
delle frecce ci sono degli squali una
bacheca rossi questo realtà è un costume
da scuola ed è apposta per confondere i
quali facile barchetta è un proprio
mentre euro ei ritorni
ok non lo so come si fa no sta
affondando di più come poteva nuotare in
mezzo agli squali però vabbè proviamoci
aiuto
aiuto che paura visto nel segmento vita
rete vedo l'ora di artisti vino nuovo
bene tutti pila che hanno mangiato sono
questi in altre no forse siamo tornati
all'ora
sottomarino hai visto che qui su questo
modo che bello è che cosa sono rino rosa
ma ci vogliono un sacco di punti per
questa che per iniziare dobbiamo per
forza andare al mondo aiuto mi fido
subito per ora nessuna scuola sono
dietro di te ma dobbiamo prendere questa
cosa ci facciamo sochi punti ok sono
punti quel decreto dove stiamo andando
lo vedo più niente sono entrato in una
spiaggetta di risaltare
che bello quasi un'ora le mani forse gli
squali non entrano dentro ma io sono qui
tu mi vedi non dovesse lei come fatto
per il raggio
che sono distratto pesciolino questo non
mi mangia non è uno squalo ei signori la
mia barca per provare la barca capito
che sta arrivando il boss ok forse uno
scolo gigante eccolo lì arriva una barca
che stava saltando come come fa saltare
con la tavola giu la mia barca quella
colorata e bolero salemi a
ruba riesco a camminare sull'acqua
quando ho quella nostra è quella che ho
scelto io non mi ruba dai mia quella
voce chiamo
io
vi aspetta aspetta ruby lasciare qui
affondare con la scuola okay e come
poter avere forse quell'altra barks in
un'altra rotta porte quello mio paolino
vetta il problema è che lì sia una pinna
di squalo gigante a noi un'orca lo
vedete c'è un organi che mi aspetta
forse questa è la mia barchetta vediamo
sviluppi su come si fa o no era una
trappola delle orche e scomparvero
guardarci il mostro di no grazie
bellissimo sempre voluto vederlo
il vostro di loch ness affatto
catapultare una barca e sta mangiando
chiunque ci stia allora che bello mi
gioco tre di locri fatti a beretta e
costruttiva come si faceva paura questa
barca o che belle gigante ex devo
scappare e mi sta rincorrendo uno squalo
è il mostro di loch ness
la scuola si sta mordendo
nella scuola qualcuno mi ha due sponde o
perché potrebbero fortunati che cosa per
me è
quasi un dio contino prendiamolo dei
preti forse siamo ad un livello troppo
basso per prendere la barca è in effetti
non abbiamo preso armi quanti ne sono di
amanda se qua ce n'è uno bellissimo
mondo il mostro di loch ness sta
arrivando bambini prendere quindi
diamanti notare digita prenderle upa
dobbiamo prendere più di amanti
possibile per avere la nostra barchetta
alcune sta sparando al mostro di loch
ness e forse abbiamo anche noi degli
oggetti
ho scoperto che sott'acqua non lo
spirito con von borries
stranamente anche nel gioco funziona
ho capito ho capito che potevo non è più
attualmente devi aprire lo zaino marche
nello zaino ci ha pensato prima la barca
ma che nello zaino
come hai fatto non saperlo aspetta esco
subito riaffiora in superficie la pro lo
zaino ammetto la barca ma eccola e ora
prendo in via mazzini a nessuno vedeva
fino quello meno massimo
il mostro di una presa mattino avuto
porca come ti ha mangiato la barca mi
chiamò il suo bello biobar calcio qui ma
non so come mai pero di squali è meglio
che scappo
dato la mia bocca ci sono grazie al
salvo almeno anche io ma c'era qua ci
sono troppi squali troppi mostri
wow che affido adesso voglio mettere
anche la mia barca anche qui è pieno di
squali guarda con the pin
farmi rendere così metto metronia barca
perché ci fermiamo qua si tratta dunque
nello zaino e abbiamo anche una spada
wow bravi a scuola mia barca
cover in olio o non ci credo
lo sconfitto il mio nome diamanti
diventa sempre più bello questo gioco ei
qualcuno si è seduto nella mia barca
vuole fare un giretto
siamo mai andati qua ma quello sei tu
io sto sony sulla sinistra cercando di
capire prestazione cercando di capire
come funziona la mia barca e funziona la
mia barba per dare salgo sulla tua
mentalità siamo già in due
vai
se questa cosa che super luccica fa
sotto per altri diamanti ma quella è la
sua marca credo dove c'è la barca che
comparsa li penso sia naturale sia la
mia
barca diamanti
bancomat e viola ei c'è questo
personaggio che sto dicendo che vuole
che andiamo a casa sua assolutamente che
ha detto che vuole darci una tutina
gratis no no o forse barca scorso che ha
sbattuto no vabbè dai andiamo a casa di
questa giocatrice che dice che vuole
darmi una tutina magari una trappola ci
sarà una squadra a casa sua
dove è finita marchigiana posso guidare
la sua barca così come dai vieni nella
mia barca così andiamo a casa di questa
giocatrice a me faccia sapendo che
questa è la mia barca io sono sulla tua
tu sei il nostro la mia ha detto che
liquido io ma non sta guidando ha detto
non posso guidare non è la mia seguimi
dice ok seguiamola mi stai seguendo ho
paura che questa giocatrice ci stia
attendendo una trappola santa ok quelle
sarà la sua casa a farsi quelle casa sua
come ha fatto a comprare una casa in
questo gioco wow oh che bello the vocato
summa
veli papà di giulia
anche la tuta da sub che bella ma come
salentine una
ci ha regalato una tutina
ringraziamo la perché l'ho ringraziata
le ho scritto andiamo ad usare voglio
provare questa tutino no però dobbiamo
diventare amici ci tiene mostre che
dividiamo vincere certo si è contento
che siamo diventati amici presto
nuotiamo un uomo forse con questa
mattina potrebbero più tempo forse sono
troppo tutti e tre assieme che bello
troviamo partiti o no
che succede o no dove sei
sbranato sì mi hanno battuto lo squalo
aiuto ho trovato un baule segreto
davvero no io credo e mi auguro
per volete che continuiamo a giocare
questo gioco super divertente lasciato
un bel mimi e ora vi lasciamo pasolini
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite e guarin serizzo